what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday in some part of the world
it's sunday night and others i'm just
getting your [__] ready for the
week
two podcasts are coming out this week
monday sam tripoli
wednesday david you're gonna love them
both
i just wanted to check in with you
[__] see what's going on
how your weekend was and to prep you
it's gonna be a big [__] weak uncle
joey
but i got you back still on twitter and
patreon
and instagram i'm gonna do some videos
for you [__] throughout the
week because i love you
but talk this cheap let's smoke a bone
to get the weak
started off on the right foot so we have
no misunderstandings you understand me
i don't want no problems with nobody we
got some tremendous reefer here i got a
couple [__] bags of tremendous reef
i leave in two [__] days the
countdown has begun
i feel good and bad at the same time
i know i'm making the right move my
family's happy
i'm happy you're happy you're upset
about the podcast don't worry about
nothing
we'll hook you up in about a month or so
let me get my head settled
but listen and i'll put the head seven
let's do a little bongarooni
out of respect for monday for my [__]
favorite people my [__] patreon
people you savages
i love the messages i love the whole
thing just keep them short
under 20 words [__] i don't want
you writing a book and [__]
anyway let's get down some guy got mad
at me what do you mean you don't want
long messages you read [__] thrilling
messages
today
oh tremendous nice on a sunday night
early monday morning to feel the full
jenna sequoia as they say over there
[__]
body you know what i'm saying me i don't
know nothing i'm just here with you guys
trying to put [__] two and two
together
watch me like this [__] house on fire
by mistake with two days left
can you believe that i think it only
happened to me that's it everything has
moved in
the office is cleaned out i gotta go
tomorrow and vacuum maybe put some
[__] paint on the walls
but that's it we're good to go
tremendous i love doing bunk hits for
you [__] suckers
it takes me back i hope you're doing one
too don't be leaving me here like
[__]
johnny charlie by myself over here doing
bang it's like a [__] half a mook
then you send pictures to the fbi next
thing you know they're doing bonkers by
myself
they sent some guy over here with white
jackets and [__]
soft clubs and next thing i'm in a room
with [__]
three other guys singing chinese songs i
don't need that [__]
so get your [__] bong ready here
you gotta get rid of the espiritos
marloes
always you gotta gotta get better bad
spirits a bad covert in the air
people wanna [__] breathe on you [__]
that i'll [__]
i'll zap you kind of suck it right in
the eyeball don't [__] around
let's do a couple more bombings and
we'll call than that i just want you to
start the [__] week
on the right foot i don't want no
[__] you know
take that taste i want everybody to
[__] do the right thing write your
goals
do your push-ups drink your water take
your [__] vitamins
get your [__] sleep and be do
something nice for somebody
once a day you call everybody talks like
arrested i don't give a [__]
but if you tell somebody one person
every day you know what let's tell you i
love you
i don't give a [__] if you tell
everybody [__] you [__] suck i don't
care
just one person if you make that day
you're solid you'll see what happens
it's that easy just do whatever open the
door
tell them the [__] shoes are nice
whatever i like you [__] ugly tattoo
you know
you got to be a gentleman
i got my little [__] tikka multi in
the church cup you know we ain't [__]
around we're going deep
deep deep into the murky waters
you know i always got my abx close by
always i got everything
i got the [__] liver cleanse
i got the cbd [__] roll on
i got the cbd abx
we got everything here cbd [__] lion
the tincture that's just [__]
tremendous you know i'm coming at you
from all directions who you think you're
dealing with joy [__] bananas
you think i would [__] bother you on
a monday morning if i was showing up you
know with three bullets
come on give yourself a [__]
breathing huh you know uncle joey
doesn't
we got other things in there but it's
nobody's business you know what i'm
saying
all right let's get down here you got
another one to go maybe two
then i'll let you off the hook right now
you're sitting there joey
what the [__] you taking me don't worry
about nothing just close your eyes it's
like lee there's a ride [__] this
is a journey
don't worry about nothing breathe and
you're gonna be fine
there you go the cove is gone all right
you won't see me dying on [__] face
time little [__]
those poor bastards dying on facetime
what a [__] shame
i'd rather shoot myself i'll stab myself
in the [__]
right in the hose you know what i'm
saying but john what are you talking
about here let's do some [__]
look what else i got today i got some b
[__] jerky i don't know how many
milligrams of thc is
but the guy who makes it [__]
delicious
oh yeah there's a [__] for the plane
right nobody even sees it coming
you're sitting there eating jerky people
like what the [__] you eating
you want peace you look you look them 10
minutes later
they're sitting in their chair what was
in that stuff
by products
you see how i'm coming at you on a
monday morning you gotta start off like
a [__] bull you understand me
you're bit slapping people you don't
give a [__] why because i said so
tell him uncle joey sent you you ain't
got time for this [__]
let me do one more bang here let's do
one more
for good measure if not you'll be
something uncle joey's a [__]
he showed up and he did do bang
let's do one more and then we'll have no
problem and i'll see you guys during the
week
don't forget sam tripoli tomorrow
morning
my man david schuler on wednesday he's
the guy that
composed the song for the church in the
beginning you know
welcome to church [__] that's a
great guy
an interesting guy give him a listen i'm
here i'm here till the 31st don't worry
about none
you're going to keep getting podcasts
and if you're on patreon
you're going to keep getting these
little check-ins they're bored with
uncle joey and there might be a bedtime
story
but tonight we'll call it a chat okay
nice and easy
you know i love you [__] i just
want to be square on you
you paid i got to give you something and
this is the best way to give it to you
smoke a few bombs if you talk to you let
you know you're a bad [__] and
guess what i'm a bad [__] too
because i'm doing business with you you
know what i'm saying so together
i'm with you you're with me and these
[__] want to be with us
[__] them a dollar joey why
because i want i want the working class
guy i don't need to listen
a dollar just give me a dollar so i give
some people
my man damage shot a few videos you know
this is for family
it's for us did i fill it up i had to
double check there for a second
i don't want to give you guys no
[__] [__] little half of [__]
balls
i love you [__] with all my
heart have a great week
don't let nobody [__] with you write
your goals
and hey this is just temporary trust me
i'm telling you
we'll be slinging dick next year just
lie low don't lose your mind
meditate right do all those things do a
couple [__]
jumping jacks you won't be all [__]
bent up out of shape trust me throughout
this thing i've been bent up by the
shape
every time you lift you swing a
kettlebell you go for a bike ride
you talk to a friend one on one in
person it makes things go by a lot
easier right i love you [__]
with all my heart that's why i'm
checking in with you
on a [__] monday morning the sling
dick so you're prepared for the [__]
world
all week alright i love you
[__] i'm all to suck your dick
thank you for being my little patreon
family